[MUSIC PLAYING]
SORIYA YIN: Hello.
My name is Soriya Yin.
I am a visiting scholar in
MIT-UTM Sustainable Cities
Program.
In this video, I will be
reviewing the Segget River
Restoration Project as a good
example of sustainable city
tourism development in Malaysia.
For centuries, people
have lived along rivers.
Rivers are a source of life.
They provide water, food,
transportation, places
for recreation, and much more.
For these reasons,
cities around the world
are connected to rivers.
As more and more people seek
to live in cities, driving up
land prices, many
urban rivers have
been filled in to make space
for growing populations.
Unfortunately, filling in rivers
can worsen flooding and water
pollution problems.
Some countries regret having
filled in their rivers
and are trying to restore them.
Malaysia is one such example.
The Segget River flows
through the center
of Johor Bahru, the capital
of Jehovah State in Malaysia.
The Segget River used to be the
primary waterway and a source
of life for many people.
When Johor Bahru
was a small town,
people sold their
products from their boats.
For many, the Segget
River was a source
of their cultural identity.
Johor Bahru has become
the second largest city
in Malaysia.
It was also seriously polluted.
Many people avoided
going near the river.
Because of its
strong odor, tourists
had no interest in
coming to the city.
They use it only as a
layover on their way
to Singh Kippur, Kuala
Lumpur, or Malacca.
In 2005, the city
decided to cover up
the river to use it as a
sewage system and amend road.
When the cover was
added, flooding wasn't.
Now Johor Bahru wants to
become a world-class city.
It seeks to expand tourism.
To achieve this
goal, the city wants
to restore the Segget River.
To do this, it will
take the cover off,
build water treatment plants,
introduce flood mitigation
systems, and beautify
the river, making
it attractive for
recreation and business.
Mr. Abd Halim, a project
management officer
from the Iskandar Regional
Development Authority,
explained the rationale.
ABD HALIM: We added the
[INAUDIBLE] Johor Bahru.
So first what we call it
a [INAUDIBLE] syndrome,
where there's no population,
declining businesses, then
no activities.
The River Sungai Segget
is heavily polluted,
and they say that Johor is
smelly because of untreated
[INAUDIBLE] of pollution.
Again, no pollution, no
business and all that.
So with that issue, or what we
call it [INAUDIBLE] syndrome,
we initiated this Johor
Bahru transformation program,
and then we seek government
funding, federal government
funding.
This initiative
started 2010 in detail.
We do all the design
calculation, design detailing.
So [NON-ENGLISH] we successfully
secured government funding,
a ceiling cost of about 240
million for this project.
SORIYA YIN: At first,
digging up the river
in the middle of the city
sounded like a crazy idea.
The cost would be substantial,
and a lot of people
would be affected.
My recent study
of Johor's effort
to promote sustainable
city tourism
found that the Segget River
Restoration Project is
a valuable and noteworthy idea.
Mrs. Norbaizura
Binti, a city planner,
explained how Johor
Bahru is seeking
to promote environmental
and cultural conservation,
foster economic development,
and ensure physical connectivity
and walkability.
NORBAIZURA BINTI: So the lesson
learned, by covering the river,
is only the upper-- the
short-term solution.
For the long-term solution, this
is what we did on this side.
We tried to settle the
environment issue, the flood
issue.
We tried to make the river
as the heart of the city.
To make a vibrant city,
we have to do that.
There's a lot of history
for Johor Bahru's center,
so it's so important for
[INAUDIBLE] sanitation.
We want to increase the
economic value, the environment,
and the identity of Johor Bahru.
And now we are trying
to rebranding the image
and identity of Johor Bahru.
We want the new brand for
Johor Bahru city center.
So we benchmark [INAUDIBLE],
just [INAUDIBLE] like that.
We want to promote Sungai Segget
as a new product in [INAUDIBLE]
center, the must-visit place.
It's good for environment.
It's good for the
image of the city.
public, the tourists.
If you can see the future
image for Sungai Segget,
I think all the Johor
area will be part, yes.
SORIYA YIN: The Segget River
Restoration Projects also
illustrate importance
of democratic governance
as a part of sustainable
city tourism development.
Johor Bahru has been able
to make great strides
by consulting with stakeholders,
minimizing social impacts,
providing fair compensation, and
building strong partnerships.
Mr. Abd Halim explained how
democratic governance has been
used to win the public support.
ABD HALIM: We do a lot of
engagement with stakeholders.
We call it a focus
group discussion,
meetings and workshops
and one-to-one discussion.
The first one, we started
with all the building owners,
the big, big players like
[INAUDIBLE], City Square Public
Bank, and all the big, big
business owners in this area.
So we want to know,
what is their acceptance
towards this project, including
what kind of environment
that they want to
see within this area?
The first proposal
design for this area,
we want to make it as
fully pedestrianized.
There's no motor vehicle to
be at Jalan Wong Ah Fook.
So we want to make
it pedestrianized.
So after we engage with all the
stakeholders, they not agree.
They say that the Jalan Wong
Ah Fook is a main thoroughfare
of Johor Bahru.
There's no benefit
of doing this.
So we come back to a combination
of river rejuvenation
and some sort of
public transport.
SORIYA YIN: Though
his shop was badly
affected by the
construction, Mr. Chan Lim
was happy with the project.
CHAN LIM: [NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
SORIYA YIN: Minimizing
social impact
is important for public
project management,
but having a long-term plan,
such as a city master plan,
is a major asset
for the project.
The plan provides
an overall framework
and attracts resources.
Mr. [INAUDIBLE], a board member
of Johor Area Rehabilitation
Organization, a local
social service NGO,
has a great hope
for the city plan.
SORIYA YIN: This river
restoration Project
in Johor Bahru
offers six lessons
for other cities in developing
world seeking to promote
sustainable city tourism.
First, conserving and
beautifying urban environment
is a key to promoting
sustainable city tourism.
This may involve restoring
ecological features for use
by both city residents
and tourists.
Second, sustainable
city tourism needs
to conserve urban
cultural heritage.
This is what makes
each city unique.
Cultural heritage
attracts tourists.
Third, physical connectivity,
particularly walkability,
is at the heart of
sustainable city tourism.
Tourists must be able to walk
around a city to enjoy it.
Fourth, sustainable city
tourism can and should
expand the economy of the city.
The goal is to enhance the
well-being of both locals
and tourists.
Fifth, democratic governance
is crucial to building
public support for
sustainable city tourism.
Public investment in
infrastructure, for example,
are more likely to
serve the general public
when the public is consulted on
design and finance strategies.
Last and most important,
never mess up your river.
The river will take good care of
us, if we take good care of it.
[MUSIC PLAYING]